[Musique]
lorsque le chemin de fer apparu en
angleterre un homme à cheval est porteur
d'un drapeau précédé la locomotive
c'était en 1825 cent quarante ans plus
tard en france
rien n'a changé nous sommes à pithiviers
dans le loiret et ce coureur à pied fait
partie de la fac ce plus précisément la
fédération des amis des chemins de fer
secondaires qui groupe les amoureux des
petits princes il collectionne le tout
les vieilles photos comme les vraies
locomotives
[Musique]
mais il existe en france d'autres
réseaux de chemins de fer secondaires et
chaque année l'association effectué
plusieurs voyages sur des lignes en voie
de disparition
la sortie de printemps avaient lieu
cette année sur le trajet de la petite
ceinture qui entourent paris depuis 1934
cette ligne est fermée au trafic des
voyageurs pour un jour elles furent
ouvertes point de départ la gare du nord
objectif le tour de paris en cette heure
par le moyen viennent sur de la traction
à vapeur des voyageurs j'ai voyagé sur
la petite ceinture encore en service
régulier en 1933 la dernière année où le
service voyageur fonctionner normalement
et en jeu j'ai utilisé la petite
ceinture pour le transport des voyageurs
c'est le voyais un souvenir sawaya
souvenir lui assurément ces découvertes
pour abc bien sûr la petite reine tillon
merveilleux 1 c'est merveilleux
la sécurité sociale ces pannes annoncé
partant l'été 2006 j'ai besoin de
souffler
oui et ils se portent un brassard mais
c'est la vie c'est pas ça
enfin
regardez des familles sans toit
m
sur la gauche on arrivait aux arrivées
outre en criant de raccordement de la
gare paris bestiaux dakar david c'est
pareil monsieur c'est pareil qu'avant je
crois connaître comme dans la jeunesse
il m'a changé pas mal de maisonneuve et
puis si vous avez désormais des grands
ensembles sont en construction à peu
près le la figure du temps jadis et
toujours aussi cynique ce à quoi vous
savez ces quartiers là ça n'est jamais
très jolie montre peu près la même année
sauve les dents sont venus vous pouvez
vous espérer mieux pour la suite
ah oui ça va s'arranger un peu dans le
sud de paris sera meilleure allure où
sommes nous là on doit arriver à 8
milliards
je ne trompe pas c'est sur le village on
nous le dit alors c'est peut-être vérité
quel est votre métier devenu avec le
temps un génie le privé c'est à dire les
jeunes n'ont pas ça n'a aucun rapport
avec cette affaire pour le plaisir
d'abord le passé puis après tout la
nature elle comporte toujours au chemin
de fer
lorsque
on est vieux c'est et même quand on est
jeune fils et qui est beaucoup plus
jeune qu'elle a perdue est également là
même la même maladie ça fait longtemps
que vous aimez ça arrange de toujours
qui ne s'est pas intéressée au train où
il s'agit quand on est petit rôle joue
petit train et puis quand on est grande
rejoindre en train et quand on est vieux
dont regard des trains du temps passé
une vocation contrariée
il rêvait d'entrer à la sncf il est à la
ratp
je suis non ça me plaisait pas je n'ai
que la surface ah oui
il ya tunnel
on pensait devoir assure mme hachem
poteau
le conditionnel élèves une chose on part
sur les buttes chaumont m'arrive ah oui
et non c'est une aide
[Musique]
pour moi est de me laisser la pelouse de
paris
j'avais déjà voyagé au népal en tout
ja j'ai énormément
là c'est grave
pour rien sortir et une heure
la voici
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que cela
ils iront grosse tellement vite
avant la station claude decaen alors on
va arriver on va passer au dessus de la
région du sud-est
ça se sait
[Musique]
en retard moyen de 1h être à 12h13
alors ici nous arrivons bientôt à la
gare de grenelle marchandises et une
voix va monter progressivement
c'est une fois qui appartient au métro
avec les habite l'ancien nord-sud et au
niveau gira la mer très au point qu'elle
est votre métier
cheminots
j'ai parlé des rats non enfin je me
trouve bien n'y a aucune raison au champ
centre
c'est à dire qu'il ya une chose un
changement parce que dans la semaine
quand je travaille au chemin de fer
et bien c'est le vrai le grand chemin de
fer est alors un week end et bien c'est
le petit chemin de fer à il ya une
machine à vapeur région où est ce qui
nous attend la machine temps d'air qui
nous attend vous connaissez le modèle
oms et une salaire des thunes 141 débit
mais c'est pas
[Musique]
si vous ne faites aucune différence
entre le main event and will ou le
pacifique
si vous discerner mal une 231 d'une 140
vous pouvez toujours reconnaître la
scène et admirer le pont de saint cloud
il
[Musique]
monsieur boyer où le virus ferroviaire
s'adapte de mon enfance mon père vit une
profession c'est l'enterrement de
notariat et m'emmener le dimanche
après-midi au triage de roujban ça se
passait en 1913 entre lille et roubaix
pendant plusieurs heures nous admirions
les voitures de marchands des wagons de
marchandises condé plaît qu'on appelait
à la butte
ensuite après j'ai lu des vivres dans
vos ferroviaire tels que la bête humaine
et là j'étais définitivement conquis par
la beauté et l'harmonie de la machine à
vapeur
parce que les descriptions de zola sont
inoubliables il faut jeter un voile
pudique sur les crudités qui a dans ce
volume et s'attarder surtout à la partie
essentiellement ferroviaire
d'autre part il ya aussi les souvenirs
de valery larbaud je crois aussi de
victor hugo enfin de diverses hauteurs
et ne prenez vous pas que la machine à
vapeur
ll a gardé comme on dit monsieur joulin
qui est très compétent elle a gardé
quelque chose de vivant qu'il n'y a pas
dans la machine électrique qui est terne
c'est le chemin de terre muet il n'a
plus de vie la machine elle dansait en
allaitement est une personne vivante la
locomotive est ce qu'il vous arrive de
prendre malgré tout des trains même
s'ils sont à traction électrique je les
prends par nécessité mais s'en occupe
sans enthousiasme je m'en fais je
m'enferme dans une lecture je vous aime
pas voir où je passe vous avez une
voiture
oui mais je l' ai absolument no1 parce
que je la conduis professionnellement
pour gagner ma vie et mon violon dingue
c'est dans le chemin de fer ça me
rappelle mon enfance où je courais au
pont des couronnes en 1920 d'un port à
l'autre pour recevoir la bouffée de
fumée dans la figure pour respirer cette
odeur de charbon voilà voilà les
souvenirs de jeunesse pjj et que je
garde encore à l'âge mûr
est ce que vous êtes revenu aujourd'hui
à ce point pris du champ je trouve ça
émerveillé dans un parcours aussi con
d'avoir eu trois types de machines
différents et des souvenirs inoubliables
que je garderai jusqu'à mon dernier
soupir monsieur
[Musique]
il n'ya plus de petite ceinture il n'y
aura bientôt plus de machines à vapeur
combien d'enfants auront-ils vu une
vraie locomotive
[Musique]